it is sunday again which means it's new
releases time this week with an
Australian accent you'll get Mary's
dulcet tones back in a couple of weeks
when she returns from Tokyo but until
then I'm here to fill you in on the
sweet game dedicating shelves in
becoming more for this world Skylanders
super joshs is launching into your
living room this week to help you bridge
that gap between three my toys and video
games alter stupid charges will feature
a bigger and better portal of power to
accommodate the new vehicle figurine
vehicles are classed as either ground
water or flying and the games races are
filled with obstacles and alternate
routes matching the correct character
with their vehicle will enable
supercharged mode which gives the
vehicle additional abilities on the road
these aren't your traditional thoughts
attracts though since you'll need to
finish off a bus before you hit the
finish line and complete a puzzle to
proceed come to think of it that would
make the Indy 500 a hell of a lot more
interesting superchargers arrives on ps3
ps4 360 xbox one and Wii U on sep tember
20 in North America and on iOS on
october twenty the wii u and nintendo
3ds versions are still in development
beaming in on the 27th for north america
and the 29th for europe lego dimensions
also uses a Skylanders esque portal to
pop your Lego critters into the game the
game follows Robin Frodo metal beard
Batman Gandalf and wild style after
they're pulled into vortices which shoot
them off to different dimensions get
ready to use LEGO minifigs and vehicles
along with the toy pad to enlist the
help of a bunch of recognizable
characters including shell from Portal
the twelfth doctor from Doctor Who and
Marty McFly from Back to the Future as
you puzzle platformer your way across
levels from 14 different franchise
FIFA devotees who've been growling at
our 9 out of 10 score for pro evolution
soccer 2016 can rejoice this week
because your favorite football game is
coming soon FIFA 16 is not only the
first game in the series which lets you
pick who would appear on the cover it's
also the first game to feature women's
teams so get ready to kick like a girl
as any of the 12 kick-ass women's
national teams the game also includes 78
stadiums including 50 real world venues
and it features a new training mode
where you can make your ship football
players into less [ __ ] football players
before the big game experienced euphoric
victories and devastating defeats that
you will inevitably blame on your little
pixel players when FIFA 16 launches on
the 22nd for pc ps3 ps4 360 xbox one
android and iOS so basically every
platform that nintendo didn't have a
hand in for those of you who thought the
chinese rooms and nevis equal a machine
for pigs just wasn't scary enough
frictional games the original developers
of amnesia the dark descent are back to
scare your pants off with soma soma is
set in an underwater remote research
facility with machinery that begins to
take on human characteristics and yeah
it sounds like things are going to go
full system shock very quickly the dev
have said you'll encounter a number of
strange creatures which each embody a
theme within the game why presumably
there will also be a lot of running
hiding and pleading with said beasties
to leave your insides inside all I can
tell you for sure is that I will be
playing this one with the lights on in
the daytime with the volume turned down
soma is due out for PC Mac Linux and ps4
on the 22nd leave us a comment to let me
know what you're going to be playing
this week and as usual release dates are
based on retailer listings and a subject
to change I'll catch you next week
are you human